يظهر ملوحا بيديه. انا ما زلت
على قيد الحياة. والاستخبارات
الامريكية تسرب فيديو يكشف هوية
الطرف الذي كان يريد اغتيال
بوتين. ان الاستخبارات الروسية
تعثر على مسيرات جديدة تقرر
تصفية واعضاء حكومته. الجيش
الاوكراني يبدأ هجومه المضاد
لاستعادة ما سقط في يد الجيش
الروسي. ووزير الدفاع الروسي
يدعو الى مضاعفة عجلة الانتاج
للسلاح الروسي والرئيس الايراني
يلتقي ببشار الاسد في سوريا. فهل
ذهب من اجل السعودية وتركيا?
والاطراف السودانية المتنازعة
تتفق والفصائل الفلسطينية ترد
وصافرات الانذار في تل ابيب
وامريكا تمد يدها لتصافح الصين.
الانتقام الروسي. تتسارع الاحداث
والزمن يفقد دواسة الفرامل. فمع
تصاعد الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية
واقتراب قوات موسكو من السيطرة
على باخموت بالكامل ومحاولة
اغتيال بوتين هنا تختلط الاوراق
مجددا وتتكشف الحقيقة. فبعد ان
اعلنت قوات الدفاع الجوي الروسية
تعطيل طائرتين مسيرتين حاولتا
الهجوم على قصر الكرملين وسط
موسكو. ومن الطبيعي هنا ان تتهم
موسكو كييف بالتخطيط لاغتيال
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين.
فالامر لا يستحق الذكاء ولا داعي
من استدعاء المحقق كون.
الكريملين هنا يؤكد ان الرئيس
الروسي لم يصب باي اذى جراء
الهجوم الاوكراني. واصفا الهجوم
بالعمل الارهابي. وقالت انها
تحتفظ بحق الرد على الهجوم في
المكان والزمان المناسبين. وذكرت
الرئاسة الروسية ان بوتين لم يكن
في مبنى الكرملين اثناء الهجوم
بالمسيرتين اذ كان يمارس مهامه
بمقر اقامته في منطقة نوفو
اوجاري يوفو قرب موسكو ونشرت
صورا له وهو بخير. اذا فمن الذي
نفذ الهجوم ومن اين تم اطلاق
المسيرات؟ الهجوم نفذ بواسطة
مسيرات تجارية اطلق مسافة غير
بعيدة من شارع مخوفايا القريب من
الكريملين حسب محللين عسكريين.
مما انتشر فيديو غريب قبل هجوم
المسيرة على الكريملين يظهر فيه
رجلان على قبة المبنى لحظة
انفجار المسيرات. وسائل اعلام
قالت بانه تم العثور على مسيرة
ثالثة في ضواحي موسكو والعمل جار
على تفكيك شحناتها الناسفة. آآ
قبل قليل اعلنت وزارة الطوارئ عن
آآ العثور مسيرة ايضا آآ هنا في
ضواحي العاصمة الروسية موسكو
كالومينغ. آآ طبعا هذه المسيرة
الان يجري آآ آآ تفكيك العبوة
الناسفة التي آآ موجودة معها.
حسنا حسنا موسكو اتهمت كييف
بالوقوف وراء الهجوم. فما هو رأي
الاوكران? اوكرانيا نفت صلتها
بالهجوم. اذ قالت سكرتيرة لجنة
الخارجية في البرلمان الاوكراني
سلوميا بوبراغوسكا انه لا صلة
لبلاد بالهجوم على الكريملين.
ورجحت المسؤولة الاوكرانية ان
تكون السلطات الروسية دبرت
الهجوم لتبرير تكثيف هجماتها على
اوكرانيا وفق تعبيرها. بما صرح
مسؤول رفيع في الرياسة
الاوكرانية بان الهجوم على
الكريملين لا يحقق لكييف شيئا
ولا يغير الموقف في ارض المعركة.
فمن الذي نفذه اذا؟ ايعقل ان
تكون روسيا نفسها؟ الرد الروسي
جاء على لسان نائب مجلس الامن
الروسي ديمتري ميدفيديف الذي دعا
الى تصفية الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي
واعضاء حكومته قائلا بعد
الاعتداء الارهابي اليوم لم يبقى
خيار امام روسيا سوى تصفية
زيلنسكي جسديا مع اعضاء حكومته.
لسنا بحاجة لبقاء زينيسكي على
قيد الحياة لاعلان الاستسلام غير
المشروط. دائما هناك بديل. وفي
وقت سابق قال نائب في مجلس
الدوما الروسي فيكتور سوبوليف
انه قد حان الوقت لاطلاق هجوم
صاروخي على مقر اقامة الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي. كما طالب رئيس
مجلس الدوما الروسي باستخدام
الاسلحة القادرة على ردع النظام
في كييف وتدميره. واضاف في بيان
روسيا يجب الا تتفاوض مع الرئيس
الاوكراني فولوديمرزيلنسكي بعد
الهجوم الذي نفى كييف مسؤوليتها
عنه. جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي كان قد اعلن في وقت سابق
احباط مخطط للاستخبارات العسكرية
الاوكرانية لاغتيال عدد من قادة
القرم واكد الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي ان من بين المخطط
لاستهدافهم رئيس القرم مشيرا الى
انه تم احتجاز سبعة من المشتبه
فيهم بالتخطيط لتنفيذ هجمات في
القرم والتجسس على مسؤولين فيها.
روسيا تتوعد السلطات الاوكرانية
باتخاذ اجراءات انتقامية ردا على
محاولة كييه باغتيال بوتين. فكيف
سيرد بوتين على هذه الخطوة
الجريئة? تداعيات الهجوم على
الكريملين لن تكون محصورة على
اوكرانيا بل ستشمل كل اعداء
روسيا وذلك ما دفع البيت الابيض
للتصريح بان واشنطن لا تشجع اي
هجمات اوكرانية خارج الحدود.
مضيفا لا يمكننا تأكيد صحة روسيا
لكييف بشن هجوم على الكرملين.
وقالت الناطقة باسم البيت الابيض
كارمن جامبي ان الولايات المتحدة
ليست في وضع يسمح لها بتأكيد
تفاصيل التصريحات عن الهجمات على
الكريملين. وكان وزير الخارجية
الامريكي انتون بلينكن اشار في
وقت سابق الى انه لا يستطيع
اثبات صحة اتهام روسيا بان
اوكرانيا حاولت اغتيال الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في هجوم
بطائرة مسيرة لكنه قال انه سينظر
بعين الريبة لاي شيء يصدر عن
الكرملين. وجدد بلينكن ثقة
واشنطن بقدرة كييف على استعادة
اراضيها معتبرا ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا فشل استراتيجي لروسيا
على حد تعبيره. وبالعودة الى
المعارك على الارض. صرح ما لك
شركة فاجنر انه يعتقد ان هجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد بدأ بالفعل
ليؤكد لنا وزير الروسي ذلك بعد
ان دعا الى مضاعفة انتاج بلاده
من الصواريخ والاسلحة عالية
الدقة في اسرع وقت ممكن. واضاف
ان القوات الروسية تواصل تدمير
الاسلحة التي قدمها الغرب
لاوكرانيا. مشيرا الى ان خسائر
القوات الاوكرانية خلال الشهر
الماضي تجاوزت خمسة عشر الف شخص.
فيما تستمر القوات الروسية في
مهاجمة قواعد الجيش الاوكراني في
زبروجا وخرسون وتكمل تطويق مدينة
اف دييفكا. اما قوات فاغنر فانها
تؤكد السيطرة على باخموت تماما.
والجيش الاوكراني ينفي ذلك. وفي
ظل الصراعات الدولية المستمرة
بين الدول الكبرى والضغوط
القائمة وجدت جنوب افريقيا نفسها
امام مأزق استقبال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين على اراضيها مطلع
الشهر المقبل. وذلك بسبب قرار
صادر بحقه من المحكمة الجنائية
الدولية. مما يترتب على اعتقاله.
فهل يجرؤ احد على اعتقال الدب
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين? الاحداث
والتطورات. في حادث هو الثاني
خلال اسبوع احتجزت ايران ناقلة
نفط ترفع علم بنما في مضيق هرمز
وفق ما اعلنت البحرية الامريكية.
وهو ما اكدته وكالة تسنيم
الايرانية الرسمية. لكنها لفتت
الى ان القوات البحرية التابعة
للحرس الثوري الايراني احتجزت
ناقلة اجنبية مخالفة لمياه مضيق
هرمز. وكانت البحرية الامريكية
اعلنت قبل ايام ان ايران احتجزت
ناقلة نفط ترفع علم جزر مارشال
في خليج عمان. قالت وزارة خارجية
جنوب السودان ان الرئيس تجرى
اتصالا هاتفيا مع قائد الجيش
السوداني عبدالفتاح البرهان
وقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان حميتي وافق خلاله البرهان
وحميدتي على هدنة لمدة سبعة ايام
من يوم الخميس الرابع من مايو
ايار الجاري. واضافت الخارجية ان
البرهان وحماتي وافقا بشكل مبدئي
على ارسال ممثلين لهما الى احدى
عواصم الدول الافريقية لبدء
محادثات سلام. اعلنت وزارة الصحة
الفلسطينية مقتل فلسطيني واصابة
خمسة اخرين في الغارات
الاسرائيلية التي استهدفت قطاع
غزة. هذا وتسود حالة من الهدوء
الحذر غزة مع دخول اتفاق وقف
اطلاق نار بين الفصائل
الفلسطينية في القطاع واسرائيل
حيز التنفيذ. فيما اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي العودة الى الحالة
الطبيعية في الجبهة الداخلية.
وكان سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي قد
اعلن شن غارات على قطاع غزة.
وذلك ردا على عمليات اطلاق
صواريخ من غزة باتجاه اسديروت
والمستوطنات الاسرائيلية. مما
ادى الى اصابة اسرائيلي بجروح
خطيرة. قال السفير الامريكي في
بكين ان واشنطن تريد قنوات افضل
مع الصينيين. مضيفا ان الولايات
المتحدة على استعداد لاجراء
مفاوضات مع الصين. وبان واشنطن
تريد خلق اجواء من الاستقرار في
العلاقات مع الصين. في زيارة هي
الاولى من نوعها منذ اكثر من
اثني عشر عاما اجرى الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيس محادثات
في دمشق مع نظيره السوري بشار
الاسد الذي اكد خلال اللقاء ثبات
العلاقات السورية الايرانية
واستقرارها الزيارة التي تستغرق
يومين يرافق الرئيس فيها وفد
وزاري سياسي واقتصادي رفيع.
وتضمنت الزيارة توقيع مذكرة
تفاهم للتعاون الاستراتيجي
الشامل بين البلدين.